modesty is one of the virtues to which
Wollstonecraft in her vindication of the
rights of women gives a lot of attention
and analysis to it in part to tell us
what genuine modesty is and also to try
to wean us away from mistaken or
wrongheaded conceptions of what modesty
would consist in or what it would come
from where its origins would lie and I
think this is a very important part of
her work because we still see this
rhetoric of modesty used today in ways
that you know she would criticize on the
basis of being and in some ways
detrimental to women's development so
let's look at what she has to say first
off is modesty just a feminine virtue
there there are some people who
presented it that way and you can still
find echoes of that in parts of today's
culture even in you know the talk about
modesty is sometimes there's some lip
service to how men ought to be modest
but usually it's talked about in a
different way with women attempts to
focus on things like like dress or how
they comport themselves in relation to
particularly to boys to men to you know
those sorts of issues and most impress
to say you can call that modesty if you
like but it's not what modesty really is
modesty in its genuine sense is in fact
as she says it's not a quality but a
virtue that means it's something that
has to be developed over time it's
something that develops in part by you
know exercising your rationality by you
know some sort of independence that's
not compatible with just following the
rules or dependency we'll see here talk
and a number of points about how it's
not just a matter of behaving the right
way but rather developing a quality of
character you know a lasting habit
when we when we talk about it and not
just being equality it's got to be a
quality of character that has become
part of who one is part of one's general
approach to things and Wollstonecraft
thinks that modesty is just as
appropriate just as necessary for men as
it is for women so it's not a
distinctively feminine virtue although
it is a virtue and as we'll see as we
come to the end of this it's actually
one of the virtues that's required for
the exercise of the other virtues so you
might call it a super virtue or a Metta
virtue in certain respects she goes on
and she asked well is it then just
purity of mind she says it appears to me
a proper to discriminate that purity of
mind which is the effect of chastity the
effective of you know not having sex
about you know restraining the passions
very often not just about you know not
having sex but not doing the sorts of
things that lead to having sex as well
she says that's not what modesty is
really about there are some connections
there in certain respects but it's
actually something much more global it's
not just concerned with sexuality
she says it's really a simplicity of
character that leads us to form a just
opinion of ourselves equally distant
from vanity or presumption and then she
goes on and says by no means
incompatible with a lofty khun's
consciousness of our own dignity so you
know let's think about what that means
for a minute what is it to have a just
opinion of ourselves so that means hurt
Lee putting ourselves in the proper
context in relation to other people that
means that we don't think too highly of
ourselves we don't think that we're
better than we actually are
we also don't think to lower ourselves
because you can be unjust or incorrect
going to high or going to love these are
both equally off the mark so you know
for example I've been teaching
philosophy classes now for more than
decade and a half so I can say that I am
a an experienced teacher and that I've
you know had some successes in leading
students into classic texts now does
that mean that I then you know elevate
myself to the status of well I'm just as
good as Wollstonecraft or Aristotle were
Heidegger that would be vanity that
would be presumption should I say well
I'm you know I mean really know better
than I was when I started out fifteen
years ago and I was not particularly
good at teaching fifteen years ago I had
to learn a lot of things in the process
no that would be an unjust unjustly low
opinion of myself and we can do the same
thing for all sorts of other
characteristics qualities we can compare
ourselves against others oftentimes what
she is calling modesty will consist in
and will require and this is part of why
it requires mental cultivation as well
as moral cultivation you gotta have
enough information you have to actually
have a wide enough perspective to put
things into perspective so you know if
you think about well here's a great
example think about attractiveness if
you got all of your ideas about what an
attractive person is not from looking at
people in your in your society or even
friends and family but looking primarily
at Hollywood movies at fashion magazines
and advertisements you would probably
have a very distorted conception of
where you fit into the scale you know
Park is you don't have Photoshop to you
know edit out any of your blemishes or
you know make you look more thin or you
know for men actually is it to make them
look more muscular that's funny because
there's a whole you know sort of
websites out there that are people
catching other people doing these
Photoshop things but if all that all you
had was that as your measure you would
not be able to have a good just
conception of your own attractiveness we
can do the same thing for wealth we can
do the same thing
or you know how easy natured you are how
easy you are to get along with others
and then we can also talk about you know
personal growth and where are you on the
the range of it you know a lot of people
want to think that because they draw up
a plan or they make a good intention
that's somehow that catapulted
themselves all the way to the end of the
process so you know I don't actually
need to go to the gym I just need to
sign up for a gym membership or maybe
think about exercising and now I'm you
know I'm in great shape it doesn't work
like that that's a that would be a lack
of modesty you know so forming a just
opinion of ourselves she also goes on
and says it's compatible with lofty
consciousness of our own dignity we
shouldn't think less of ourselves than
we actually deserve there are some
things that we deserve because of our
dignity and that goes into modesty so
when we talk about for example basic
human rights and the fact that nobody
should deprive us of them that's part of
our dignity and modesty insists on those
it also doesn't shrink back from from
great things she also points out that
it's not a product of chastity by itself
she's got some interesting discussions
here she says to render chastity the
virtue from which unsophisticated
modesty will naturally flow the
attention should be called away from
employments with which only exercise the
sensibility and the heart made to be
time to humanity rather than to throb
with luck so if you want to actually
cultivate modesty on the basis of
chastity what you have to do is instead
of making people just not have sex or
think about other things or take cold
showers or you know behave in a certain
way towards each other
you need to expand their minds you need
to open up their their their ranges to
other things others human capabilities
she says the regulation of behavior is
not modesty though those who study rules
of decorum are in general
termed modest women make the heart clean
let it expand and feel for all that is
human instead of being narrowed by
selfish passions and let the mind
frequently contemplate subjects which
exercise the understanding and artless
modesty will give the finishing touches
to the picture so if you want to reign
as people who are modest you actually
need to work on their their minds not
just on their behavior let's look now
yeah how she arranges these this virtue
in relation to other character traits
that she really considers vices I do
have to mention something too when she
uses the word humility and she says
modesty is not humility through the rest
of the vindication of the rights of
women
Wollstonecraft is a bit inconsistent she
will use humility in such a way as to
signify what she in this chapter is
actually calling modesty is that you
know a really big problem no just
substitute the word modesty in and the
conception of modesty when you see
humility and other chapters and you
won't get led astray it's it's sort of
nitpicky it would be you know in a lot
of respects a lack of modesty on one's
own part to be nitpicky about that when
you're already given the tools for
dealing with that intellectually no she
says modesty is something that's as
equally distant from pride or another
word for prized vanity as it is from
humility and you may not realize this
but Wollstonecraft is actually playing
out a set of distinctions that have been
talked about in philosophy for a very
long time Aristotle discusses this in
terms of the Great's old person it
becomes an issue that that's discussed
quite a bit for Christian thinkers
ranging from John Cassian to Anselm of
Canterbury it becomes an issue that's
talked about by David Hume and the
you know the 18th century as well
somebody who will stone craft is very
familiar with and Wollstonecraft
is is developing a position which in
certain respects is mapping on to those
other positions
she says that modesty is different than
humility she wants to insist on this why
she says that it's a soberness of mind
which teaches a man not to think more
highly of himself than he ought to think
so there it starts to sound like
humility don't think too highly of
yourself but you shouldn't think too
lowly of yourself either she says it
should be distinguished from humility
because humility is a kind of self
abasement so the humble person actually
treats themselves as having less value
than they really do it's a self
abasement meaning one pushes oneself
down you know boughs down to somebody
else I'm not worthy that sort of thing
so it's in some respects true little
soft Worth and eventually it catches on
it becomes that you know part of the
mindset of the person now there are a
lot of people who are forced into
situations in which they have to behave
with what we're calling humility not
with modesty think about workplaces
where people are forced to you know suck
up to two bosses who are really you know
terrible people and have nothing to
offer to the human race other than you
know being able to dole out jobs and
yell at people think about marriages
think about relationships that are
abusive in which one person is
constantly pushing the other person down
on exploiting them taking advantage of
them and in which the other person
eventually comes to accept that point of
view about themselves and to treat
themselves as if they don't have any
value it takes a lot to work one's way
out of that when it's become a written
rasa mated within
one's mind and character so with
humility one when values oneself to to
little with pride or vanity one values
oneself too much more than one ought to
you know it could be on the basis of
genuine qualities that a person has you
know for example I play the banjo and
I'm not you know very I'm not
particularly good at it and I don't
actually do the sort of practicing that
I should do that you know in order to
get good so it would be really silly for
me to say you know I'm as good as bela
Fleck who is this amazing banjo player
who you know not only can play you know
traditional music but can play all sorts
of contemporary stuff is like bands does
concerts that would be too much you know
if somebody came up to me and said well
can you play it all and I said no no no
I can't play in public at all Oh that'll
be a little bit too little probably I
should be more independent than this end
now notice one of the things that
Wollstonecraft says is going to go along
with this when we'll come back to the
modesty partner moment what happens what
do you when a person who's humble is
offer the opportunity to do something
they beg off they say I can't do that
they're unwilling to undertake the sorts
of things that they want to be doing in
order to advance themselves in order to
you know help other people in order to
make the world a better place there are
they're unwilling to take a chance
people who are proud on the other hand
or who are vain way too too willing to
jump into things and oftentimes they
screw things up as a result as a matter
of fact a lot of the problems that we
have in human life human lives are
caused by human beings who take on more
than they are actually up to and screw
it up and then don't want to let anybody
know that they screwed it up and they
have to cover it up
at least the bigger and bigger and
bigger problems and you know they're not
able to say yeah I wasn't the man or the
woman for the job
modesty keeps us from doing that because
modesty tells us just taking on the
stuff that you can actually do
just take on the projects just you know
commit yourself where you can actually
do it and this doesn't necessarily mean
you know crew being oneself bad quite a
bit like she says it's compatible with a
lofty consciousness so she has some
examples here Milton was not arrogant
when he when he suffered a suggestion of
judgment - escaping that proved a
prophecy you know think about what goes
into creating great worse Milton wrote
Paradise Lost he also wrote a bunch of
other things as well that are that are
quite brilliant if Milton had been
humble he wouldn't wouldn't have done
any of those sort of things if Milton
had been vain he probably would have
screwed it up by being modest he was
actually able to create a great work of
genius General Washington she says nor
was General Washington when he accepted
the command of the American forces the
latter has always been characterized as
a modest man had he been merely humble
he would have probably have shrunk back
your resolute afraid of trusting to
himself the direction of an enterprise
on which so much dependent as modest
people who you want to be the ones who
you actually give power and authority to
now notice how far away we are in
talking about this from modestly
conceived as this you know shrinking
violet feminine virtue you know which
consists in like picking out the right
kind of clothes with the hemlines not
too high above the knee or you know with
too much showing this is you know like
worlds apart from the way that a lot of
people in in our own culture and in
Wollstonecraft's culture we're using
this term modesty it's really a matter
of one's entire person in relation to
other people let's go on and talk about
something that she calls bashfulness
this is something that people often
mistake for modesty modesty yeah she's
got some really interesting things to
say about it
she says I don't mean to confound it
with bashfulness bashfulness is so
distinct from modesty that the most
bashful laughs or
raw country lout often become the most
impudent for their bashfulness being
merely the instinctive timidity of
ignorance custom soon changes it into
assurance so when a person is bashful
they hang back
not because they you know really have a
just estimate of themselves it's not
coming from knowledge it's actually
coming from ignorance ignorance about
where they fit in so they're more prone
to treat themselves as humble and we can
sort of draw an arc here that runs
through bashfulness from humility to
pride or vanity as soon as they start to
understand the situation that they're in
and not to feel bashful they become
impudent as a result they've become like
the prideful or vanity and she gives an
example with with with prostitution she
says a shameless behavior the
prostitutes may illustrate this remark
that trample on virgin bashfulness with
a sort of bravado and glorying in their
shame become more audacious ly lewd than
men
however depraved to whom the sexual
quality has not been gratuitously
granted but these poor ignorant wretches
never had any modesty to lose when they
consigned themselves to this for modest
ease of virtue not equality they were
only bashful innocence and then once
they lost their innocence their shame
faced and this was rudely brushed off
she says something really interesting
here a virtue would have left some
vestiges in the mind had it been
sacrificed a passion to make us respect
the grand ruin but there's nothing like
that left in this and we could say the
same thing about all sorts of other
cases where somebody behaves in a
bashful way and then they start to
figure out you know the way things
really work and how things are situated
and they launched over into this side of
pride or vanity which she's calling
audacity there's another thing that she
talks about as well as opposed to to
modesty when she's talking about
chastity
she says that chastity is not going to
produce modesty though it may produce
propriety of conduct
waahh modesty and we'll she says
heartily disclaim and refuse to
well with that debauchery of mind which
leads a man coolly to bring forward
without a blush indecent delusions
obscene witticisms in the presence of a
fellow-creature
unless she says how much more modest is
the libertine who obeys the the call of
appetite or fancy than the lewd Joker
who sets the table in a roar so she's
saying look if you're gonna be kind of a
you know obsessed with sex
and trying to you know make an issue of
it all the time you're actually better
off if you're the libertine the the
player who is just trying to get sex was
just trying to you know find a warm body
to you know spend the night with then
being the kind of person who's
constantly making lewd rude allusions
who's telling dirty jokes who's you know
doing that sort of thing she calls that
a matter of immodesty or debauchery and
she she has something really interesting
to say about this a little bit further
on one reason why people would you know
say that you know this sort of thing
goes on is the sexes are involved in a
state of warfare and she says well at
the beginning but they're not really in
a state of warfare but if you want to
use that sort of metaphor if they're if
they're really to act that way then let
the Mac nobley or let pride whisper to
them the victory is mean when they
merely vanquished sensibility and she
says until matter more chaste women are
going to be immodest women are going to
be engaging in this sort of stuff as
well it unless men remember we've talked
about this several times men and women
mutually improve each other or corrupt
each other if men can't actually develop
modesty in this sense then she says it's
ridiculous to expect women to wear
indeed could modest women find husbands
from whom they would not continually
turn with disgust she says and here's a
great line modesty must be equally
cultivated by both sexes or it must or
will ever remain a sickly hothouse plant
meaning something that you can only grow
in a greenhouse not something that can
actually
the real world so now I want to end with
this by talking about why modesty is so
particularly central and important for
Wollstonecraft she says that perhaps
there is not a virtue that makes us so
kindly with every other as modesty it's
the pale Moonbeam that renders more
interesting every virtue it softens
giving mild grandeur to the contracted
horizon so it's something that's needed
in order for the other virtues to have
the attractiveness that they have a
person who is courageous but is also
proud or you know doesn't have a the
right assessment of themselves not as
attractive as a person who actually has
a proper self-assessment of themselves
the courage that they have and its
relation to other people so she says the
possession of virtue of any denomination
is incompatible with ignorance and
vanity you must acquire soberness of
mind or you will remain in a doubtful
dependent situation here she's talking
to women in particular and saying if you
actually want to acquire independence
you're gonna have to cultivate this
virtue modesty which is not the way it's
been depicted to you or it has to do
with you know mirror behavior usually of
a sexual nature and more has to do with
the entire character of a person